un mes antes de cumplir 119 años
falleció conocida como la hermana hombre
nació en el sur de Francia en 1904 y
trabajó como institutriz antes de
ordenarse religiosa a los 40 años se
convirtió en la mujer oficialmente más
longeva del mundo cuando murió la
japonesa cane Tanaka a los 119 años en
su cumpleaños número 117 recordó a las
muchas personas que había conocido a lo
largo de su vida
me da gran placer haber conocido a todos
aquellos a los que he querido
y dar gracias a Dios por habérmelos dado
tras quedarse ciega en los últimos 13
años de su vida empezó a vivir en una
residencia de Tulum donde seguía
comiendo chocolate y bebiendo un vaso
divino todos los días también sobrevivió
al Coby a principios de 2021 sin embargo
Desde hacía varios años no ocultaba
cierto hastío y lamentaba haber perdido
parte de sus capacidades físicas
yo representaba la libertad
pero ahora es terrible no ser capaz de
hacer ni un gesto sola Según uno de los
administradores de la residencia donde
vivía para la hermana hombre fue una
Liberación irse tras su muerte el título
ha pasado a la española María brañaz
morera de 115 años